[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
norbert könig ist auch dabei für den
sport guten abend
am flughafen in der afghanischen
hauptstadt kabul spielen sich
erschütternde szenen ab
flucht als letzte hoffnung nach der
machtübernahme der taliban versuchen
tausende das land zu verlassen
deutschland schickt transportmaschinen
zur evakuierung
angst vor der nächsten katastrophe in
haiti steigt die zahl der erdbebenopfer
weiter jetzt nähert sich tropensturm
grace und
mehr nutzen als risiken die ständige
impfkommission rät nun doch kinder und
jugendliche ab zwölf jahren zu impfen
[Musik]
vor einer guten stunde kam das
eingeständnis des deutschen
außenministers zu afghanistan es gebe
nichts zu beschönigen wir alle die
bundesregierung die nachrichtendienste
und die internationale gemeinschaft
haben die lage falsch eingeschätzt sagt
heiko maas viel schneller als erwartet
haben die radikalislamischen taliban die
macht im land zurückerobert in der
hauptstadt kabul haben sie den
präsidentenpalast besetzt demonstrativ
rollen sie die afghanische flagge
zusammen am flughafen chaotische szenen
verzweifelt versuchen tausende sich noch
irgendwie an bord eines flugzeugs zu
retten in den tumulten sterben
mindestens fünf menschen mit berichtet
chaos vor dem flughafen karten
es fallen schüsse verzweifelte menschen
familien mit kindern die irgendwie weg
wollen solange es noch geht mittendrin
aber schon schwer bewaffnete taliban
kämpfer die immer wieder das feuer
helfen in der menge auch flüchtlinge die
aus der provinz vor den taliban in die
hauptstadt kabul gefahren waren in der
hoffnung hier sicher zu sein
wir haben keine lebensgrundlage mehr
unser zuhause mussten wir zurücklassen
und zu essen haben wir hier auch nichts
auf dem flughafengelände herrscht
entsetzen menschen versuchen mit aller
kraft an bord einer maschine zu gelangen
obwohl der linienflugverkehr eingestellt
wurde auch militärflugzeuge konnten
vorübergehend nicht mehr landen weil
sich tausende auf die rollbahn drängten
verzweifelt an bereits staaten der
amerikanische militärmaschinen
klammerten vergeblich bemühten sich
us-soldaten das gelände zu sichern
bei schusswechseln wurden nach
us-angaben zwei bewaffnete getötet der
evakuierungseinsatz von drei deutschen
transportflugzeugen musste verschoben
werden die maschinen warten in
aserbaidschan im präsidentenpalast
ließen sich unterdessen die neuen
machthaber filmen ihre führer danken
gott für den sieg gratulierten ihren
kämpfern und versuchten zugleich die
afghanische bevölkerung zu beruhigen
wir werden der afghanischen nation
dienen und wir werden für sicherheit und
ein besseres leben sorgen
soweit das versprechen viele afghanen
und afghaninnen erinnern sich aber noch
mit schrecken an die dunklen jahre der
gewaltherrschaft der taliban vor mehr
als 20 jahren der generalsekretär der
vereinten nationen appellierte an die
taliban die menschenrechte aller bürger
insbesondere von frauen und mädchen zu
respektieren die kommenden tage seien
entscheidend
was bedeutet die machtübernahme der
taliban für all die die anders denken
was droht frauen und mädchen die stadt
ghasni wurde schon am donnerstag von den
islamisten eingenommen ein wichtiges
handelszentrum ghasni liegt rund 150
kilometer von kabul entfernt und hat
etwa
180.000 einwohner katrin eigendorf
berichtet in der provinzmetropole
ghasemi haben sie in nur vier tagen
alles übernommen taliban regeln den
verkehr betreiben die krankenhäuser
schulen gerichte us-militär fahrzeuge
waffen sie sind gut ausgerüstet alles
hat ihnen der gouverneur überlassen
kampflos
verwaltungsangestellte lehrer ärzte
sogar journalisten
sie alle arbeiten jetzt unter der
führung der taliban
viele tausend sind geflohen wer
geblieben ist lebt jetzt unter dem
gesetz der scharia
die fernseh und radiosender senden und
arbeiten nach scharia gesetz mindestens
15 mitarbeiter der alten belegschaft
arbeiten für uns die anderen haben wir
kontaktiert
gasen nie so sagen die taliban ist jetzt
teil des islamischen emirats afghanistan
überall weht die flagge der taliban
kritisch äußert sich niemand vor der
kamera aber es gibt auch menschen die
zufrieden sind
seitdem ist zum glück das islamische
emirat gibt sind die straßen die vorher
blockiert waren wieder offen die leute
sind glücklich wie schnell sie nicht nur
die stadt einnehmen konnten sondern auch
alle staatlichen stellen zeigt sie
kämpfen brutal sind aber auch gut
organisiert moderner als die taliban die
vor 20 jahren in afghanistan herrschten
und sie wissen um die macht der medien
ein eigener radiosender verkündet die
neuen leitlinien mit videoclips füllen
sie ihre social media kanäle eine
islamistische diktatur so wird es
künftig in ganz afghanistan aussehen
gehen wir nach washington zur elmar
theveßen immer was bedeutet dieses
scheitern in afghanistan für die usa und
präsident biden
erschüttert natürlich sowohl hier als
auch weltweit das vertrauen in die
glaubwürdigkeit und auch in die
kompetenz dieser us-regierung joe biden
wollte ja nach vier jahren deutschland
genau dieses vertrauen wieder herstellen
das weiße haus schiebt jetzt die schuld
auf die afghanische armee die ganz
offenbar die eigene bevölkerung nicht
verteidigen wolle und auf die
afghanische regierung die ihre eigenen
soldaten im stich lasse aber präsident
biden wird nachher wenn er hier im
weißen haus sich an die nation wenden
will im laufe des abends natürlich
erklären müssen warum es keinen plan b
gab gegen das was sich abzeichnen konnte
und das bleibt natürlich diese
fehleinschätzung von ihm und von den
geheimdiensten und auch diese
katastrophale planung das wird an ihm
hängen bleiben auch wenn und auch das
gehört zur wahrheit dazu die
überwältigende mehrheit der amerikaner
und auch der politiker bei demokraten
und republikaner der festen überzeugung
sind dass der abzug aus afghanistan
richtig ist dann knapp washington mrt
wissen die westlichen staaten versuchen
jetzt in höchster eile ihre bürger und
ausländische hilfskräfte aus afghanistan
raus zu holen die bundeswehr hat mehrere
a400m transporter losgeschickt sie
sollen die menschen von kabul ins
benachbarte usbekistan bringen in die
hauptstadt taschkent sie ist als
drehkreuz für die evakuierungen
vorgesehen von dort geht es weiter nach
deutschland thomas reichert
abflug aus wunstorf zu einem der
gefährlichsten bundeswehreinsätze a400m
transportflugzeugen sind auf dem weg
nach afghanistan
mit an bord fallschirmjäger die
absichern was in kabul gelingen soll wir
werden in einem robusten einsatz in
einem robusten mandat solange es die
möglichkeiten vor ort zu lassen so viele
wie menschen so viele menschen wie
möglich aus kabul aus afghanistan raus
holen wie lange das angesichts der lage
in kabul noch möglich sein wird ist
unsicher sicher scheint dass die
bundesregierung wertvolle zeit verspielt
hat nach zdf-informationen gegen das
innenministerium noch am freitagabend
davon aus mit einem angriff auf
kabellose erst nach dem vollständigen
abzug der us-truppen ende august zu
rechnen ähnlich sei es das auswärtige
amt aus minister mars behauptete noch
bis vor kurzem eine machtübernahme der
taliban stehe nicht bevor es gibt auch
nichts zu beschönigen wir alle die
bundesregierung die nachrichtendienste
die internationale gemeinschaft wir
haben die lage falsch eingeschätzt
bereits ende juni beantragten die grünen
im bundestag ein großzügiges
aufnahmeverfahren für afghanische
ortskräfte union und spd lehnten den
antrag mit den stimmen der afg damals ab
das zeigt wie fatal es war dass man von
seiten der deutschen bundesregierung des
auswärtigen amtes die augen vor der
realität verschlossen hat trotz oder
wegen der versäumnisse armin laschet
betont heute deutschland müsse sich nun
von neuen flüchtlingsströmen wappnen
europäische union muss sich darauf
vorbereiten
dass es
flüchtlingsbewegungen richtung europa
geben könnte
2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen
derweil ist weiter unklar ob die
bundeswehr maschine in kabul überhaupt
landen können um menschen aus höchster
not zu retten
waren wir theo koll in berlin wie konnte
es passieren dass die lage in
afghanistan so falsch eingeschätzt wurde
nun offensichtlich ist der gesamte
westen einer gemeinsam und auch
vielfachen selbsttäuschung aufgesetzt
man hat im land am hindukusch zwar eine
politische struktur verordnet die war
aber genauso wenig stabil wie die
hochgerüstete und ja mit milliarden
unterstützte afghanische armee und beide
sind jetzt wie kartenhäuser zusammen
gebrochen und sowohl der deutsche als
auch der us-geheimdienst haben die lage
offensichtlich völlig falsch
eingeschätzt und ranghoher us general
es habe an einem grundlegenden
verständnis des landes gefehlt zitat von
ihm wir wussten nicht was wir daten im
moment äußert sich gerade die kanzlerin
auch zu afghanistan wenn wir mal rein
die entwicklung in afghanistan ist aber
natürlich auch bitter für deutschland
und die anderen verbündeten nationen die
unterführung der vereinigten staaten von
amerika und der nato nach den
terroranschlägen des 11 september 2001
20 jahre in afghanistan gegen den
terrorismus und für freiheitliche
strukturen gekämpft haben die
verbündeten und auch unsere bundeswehr
natürlich haben zusammen mit vielen
zivilen organisationen wichtiges
geleistet
niemals dürfen wir die menschen
vergessen die diesen einsatz mit ihrem
leben unter ihnen auch 59 deutsche oder
aber mit narben an leib und seele
bezahlt haben und deshalb denke ich in
dieser stunde gerade auch an den schmerz
ihrer angehörigen und freunde gerade
jetzt da alles so vergeblich erscheint
so weit jetzt in diesen minuten die
bundeskanzlerin wir alle schauen vor
allem im moment auf den blamablen und
chaotischen abzug aber die wirklich
bitteren stunden dürften den menschen in
afghanistan noch bevorstehen und mit
jeder nachricht über menschliche opfer
liegen die krassen westlichen
fehleinschätzung und fehlentscheidungen
jahr schwerer und umso größer wird auch
die politische mitverantwortung auch
unserer politisch handelnden dankeschön
nach berlin theo koll war dass
wir sind die taliban diese
selbsternannten gotteskrieger die so
viel angst verbreiten und die es
geschafft haben die internationalen
truppen zu zermürben noten leinhos hat
antworten
steinzeit islamismus so erinnert die
welt dass afghanistan der taliban in den
90er jahren ein reich der finsternis
ohne musik und filme ohne frauenrechte
ein land in dem öffentliche
hinrichtungen alltag waren solche
exzesse sind auch jetzt denkbar so
experten aber sie sind weniger
wahrscheinlich auf der anderen seite
haben haben wir auch die berichte der
entwicklungsorganisationen die ja sagen
sie arbeiten zum teil gut mit den
taliban zusammen weil die taliban
natürlich jetzt auch in der situation
sind dass sie die von müssen um ihre
legitimation innerhalb der bevölkerung
auch zu erhöhen haben die taliban also
dazu gelernt ihr vergleichsweise
unblutiger sturm auf kabul spricht dafür
es gibt bis jetzt noch keine berichte
darüber dass es zu massenverhaftungen
massen erschießungen müssen
misshandlungen von
regierungsmitarbeitern von streitkräften
gekommen ist die sich ergeben haben
bislang geben sich die kämpfer eher
zurückhaltend denn rachsüchtig und in
denen bereits eroberten provinzen können
frauen und mädchen weiter zur schule
gehen allerdings müssen sie in tschador
tragen also es ist dieses schwarze
gewand was halt nur das gesicht
freilässt anthony war
aber das ist ja schon mal ein zeichen
dass sie zumindest schulunterricht also
hoffen sich die sekunde unterricht zu
lassen ob es dabei bleibt hängt vom
machtkampf innerhalb der taliban ab ob
sich die fundamentalistischen
feldkommandeur durchsetzen oder die eher
moderaten taliban gruppen die verhandelt
haben
mehr zur lage in afghanistan erfahren
sie direkt nach uns in einem zdf spezial
auf heute de und in unsere zdf heute app
finden sie außerdem alle aktuellen
entwicklungen in einem live blog
zusammengefasst nach
haiti zwei tage nach dem schweren
erdbeben ist die zahl der toten dort auf
mehr als 1300 gestiegen besonders
betroffen ist die region im südwesten
des verarmten inselstaat rund um das
epizentrum etwa
125 kilometer westlich der hauptstadt
autocross und jetzt droht auch noch ein
tropensturm die suche nach den
vermissten dürften damit noch
schwieriger werden claudia bates
berichtet
endlich kommt hilfe in den entlegenen
gebieten an schweres gerät und
rettungstrupps die dabei helfen zu
räumen und so vielleicht noch
verschüttete lebend zu retten sie
arbeiten gegen die zeit zwei tage nach
dem erdbeben und unmittelbar vor dem
heraufziehenden sturm sie wollen ihre
toten beerdigen die zwischen all der
zerstörung und inmitten von chaos noch
keinen würdigen ort gefunden haben in
den straßen brechen sich trauer und
verzweiflung bahn
[Musik]
mehr als 13.000 gebäude sind nach einer
ersten bilanz völlig zerstört ähnlich
viele sind beschädigt zigtausend
menschen sind betroffen verletzt oder
ohne dach über dem kopf schlafen in
provisorischen zelten oder draußen
wir schlafen auf der straße es ist so
schwer für uns jetzt wir können nirgends
hin weil unser haus zerstört ist und
keine behörde kümmert sich um uns
es fehlt an allem die stromleitungen
sind kaputt nahrung ist knapp und
sauberes wasser die versorgung eine
herausforderung da die straßen hierher
zum teil verschüttet sind aber die
internationale hilfe ist angelaufen die
usa schicken such und rettungsteams und
fangen an die verletzlichsten in
sicherheit zu bringen
aber erst in den nächsten tagen nach dem
sturm sind die folgen des erdbebens
abzuschätzen
zum thema corona da gibt es wichtige
neuigkeiten von der stiko der
impfkommission die empfiehlt jetzt doch
alle kinder ab 12 gegen korona zu impfen
bisher war sie sehr zurückhaltend nun
gebe es aber ausreichend daten sagt die
stiko und kommt zu dem schluss dass der
nutzen der impfung auch bei kindern die
risiken überwiegen christiane hübsche
hat die details
wochenlang hatte sich die ständige
impfkommission daten aus den usa kommen
lassen dort sind schon fast zehn
millionen kinder und jugendliche geimpft
einzig beobachtete komplikationen war
die herzmuskelentzündung die vorrangig
bei jungen auftrat aber gut behandelbar
ist deshalb gibt die stiko heute grünes
licht für alle ab 12 bisher wissen wir
dass diese herzmuskelentzündung die ja
sehr selten vorkommen durchaus nicht
gefährlich verlaufen sind die meisten
kinder sind sehr gut wieder gesund
geworden mussten im krankenhaus
behandelt werden aber haben nach dem was
wir bisher wissen keine folgeschäden
behalten und so heißt es im
beschlussentwurf dass die vorteile der
impfung gegenüber dem risiko von sehr
seltenen impfnebenwirkungen
überwiegen
bundesgesundheitsministeriums spahn
begrüßt den schwenk der stiko das ist
eine gute nachricht für kinder für
jugendliche und für ihre eltern gibt es
nun die klare empfehlung sich impfen zu
lassen die politik hatte öffentlich
druck auf die stiko gemacht ihre
empfehlungen zu ändern der bremer
kinderarzt stefan trapp glaubt mit dem
heutigen tag werde die entscheidung für
familien leichter gemacht sein vertrauen
in die stiko ist ungebrochen die
unabhängigkeit einer solchen
organisation ist essentiell deshalb
finde ich es ganz zentral dass die stiko
oder ihrer eigenständigkeit bewahrt hat
und eben wirklich abgewartet hat bis sie
auch gute daten hat und eine gewisse
zeit lang auch den politischen druck
standgehalten hat bund und länder
versichern erneut einen impfzwang an
schulen wird es nicht geben auch die
impfung von kindern bleibe eine
persönliche entscheidung
neue wege geht baden württemberg
unabhängig von der inzidenz sind dort
seit heute kontakt beschränkungen und
regelungen für private feiern aufgehoben
auch dürfen zum beispiel theater wieder
komplett öffnen dafür müssen ungeimpfte
in vielen bereichen negative schnee
tests oder sogar pcr tests vorweisen die
masken pflicht im nahverkehr und in
innenräumen bleibt für alle bestehen
und jetzt der sport du bist dran hat ja
mit einer bemerkenswerten entscheidung
am grünen tisch der vfl wolfsburg ist
nämlich nachträglich aus dem dfb pokal
wettbewerb ausgeschlossen worden weil
trainer mark van bommel im erste
rundenspiel bei preußen münster einen
regelverstoß unterlaufen war der
niederländer hatte in der verlängerung
admir mehmedi und damit den sechsten
spieler eingewechselt obwohl nur fünf
erlaubt sind das dfb-sportgericht
wertete das spiel mit 2 zu 0 für den
viertligisten wolfsburg hatte das spiel
auf dem grünen rasen 3 zu 1 gewonnen
zwei trainer hoffen kurz nach
saisonbeginn schon auf den ersten titel
mit ihrem neuen verein marco rose mit
borussia dortmund und julian nagelsmann
mit dem fc bayern wollen den super cup
gewinnen im duell pokalsieger gegen
meister noch immer wartet julia
nagelsmann als neuer bayern-coach auf
den ersten sieg seines teams auch am
freitag reichte es trotz eines treffers
von dauerbrenner robert lewandowski in
mönchengladbach nur zu einem 1 zu angst
wir morgen gewinnen dann nochmal den
ersten die dieses jahr das ist ein
richtiges spiel keine frage gegen gegner
der sehr gut gestartet sind die
bundesliga gleich fünf dortmunder tore
am samstag gegen frankfurt schenken
spielern und fans einen saisonauftakt
nach maß vor allem die norwegische
galionsfigur erling holland mit zwei
treffern und einem assist ließ den
ausfall von sechster unter stammkräften
zur nebensache werden und einige fans
haben in der vorfreude auf den super gab
sogar ein paar tränen vergossen
schwarz-gelbe freudentränen natürlich
abzuwarten noch glückstränen werden
vielen dank
wechselhaft und windig das sind die
schlagworte für die wetterprognose von
morgen einzelheiten hat gleich katja
oliver danach folgt das zdf spezial zu
afghanistan und um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt sie marietta slomka im heute
journal
danke für ihr interesse
alles gute ihnen und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute war das wetter in
deutschland mal wieder dreigeteilt
besonders über baden württemberg und
bayern zogen zum teil auch kräftige
regenschauer und gewitter hinweg sie
sehen das ganz gut an unserer violetten
farbe in einem streifen ungefähr von
berlin bis zum oberrhein zeigte sich am
nachmittag häufiger die sonne und dann
gab es diese dichteren wolken die davon
nordwesten herankamen die brachten regen
mit und zum teil auch gewitter wie rund
um flensburg und auch jetzt in der nacht
müssen wir in schleswig-holstein noch
auf gewitter uns gefasst machen sonst
ziehen über norddeutschland regenschauer
hinweg und am längsten regnet es wohl
noch am alpenrand die temperaturen
sinken auf 14 grad auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und bis 7 grad in
der eifel und morgen liegen die werte in
den mittelgebirgen meist um die 15 grad
sonst sind es 17 18 grad am wärmsten
wird es am oberrhein mit 21 grad und
auch morgen ziehen noch bei einem
starken bis stürmischen wind etliche
regenschauer und gewitter über
norddeutschland hinweg am nachmittag
kommen seien hiervon den niederlanden
und belgien hier neue wolken heran die
auch wieder regen dabei haben viele von
uns bekommen aber morgen einen
freundlichen tag mit sonnenschein und
wolken und wechselhaft geht es dann auch
in den nächsten tagen weiter dabei
nehmen die sonnen anteile von tag zu tag
zu guten abend